[Music]  hey Dylan are you doing at Clyde please  proceed with caution  welcome to Jefferson the Free State you  think you can trust this woman my  sensors are better than a polygraph I'll  take it slow don't worry I know I'm  complicated you're the one with the  computer in your head I was thinking  maybe you could help me figure out my  situation consider this in advance what  exactly are you aiming for it's buried  on his property  310 ounce bars 42 million dollars two  thousand acres is a lot of digging when  I first met him he was a shaman he was a  healer he used his witchcraft to help  people witchcraft  he's developing warfare technologies you  ready believe everything she tells you  to cyber are all about the money  quiet I count 15 farmhands all chipped  and trackable  [Music]  much appreciated mr. Clark as it is  written civilizations crumble but gold  remains quiet I'll help us find it right  [Music]  what do you want my goal I'm not greedy  just my half  [Music]  you